greetings of creatures
it is i
crypto one three seven
or one three four
the numbers are random this planet is
now part of the furore on empire
and the benevolent masters have returned
once again to harvest more of your puny
dna
for scientific research purposes of
course
and now i shall allow my human specimen
to explain our plans for world
domination
with how crazy the year 2020 has been
expecting an alien invasion probably
won't be too far-fetched of a notion to
consider fans are in for a nostalgic
trip with the newest remake of the
highly popular destroyer humans game
some huge boxes has recently been down
onto our doorstep and we can't wait to
share these juicy merchandise with you
guys we will also be giving away
[Music]
this
your very own destroy humans crypto 137
edition as well as the digital copy of
the game on either pc or playstation 4
so stick around to the end of this video
to find out more
you know what time it is
roll the thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
show us some love by hitting that
subscribe button and giving us a like so
that other geeks can get a chance to
watch this video and follow us on our
social media channels so you can stay
updated to more giveaways geeky news and
tidbits and now back to the video
first up we have the dna collectors
edition
the collection features a 9 inch or 23
centimeters crypto and car figurine and
much more aliens seem to love adopting
our grass-grazing friends and the crypto
and configuring gives a little nod to
those absurd stories
and best of all it glows
in the dark
next flex your fingers and release the
attention from gaming with the eye
popping anti-stress alien toy
the generous furor masters have also
graced us humans with a crypto head
shaped metallic keychain
they've also included six lithographs
featuring scenes from the alien invasion
which are most certainly not alien
propaganda the dna collectors edition
comes at a sweet sweet price of 170
singapore dollars while bigger may not
always be better we were certainly
godsmacked by the size of the premium
crypto 137 edition
going the extra mile for this extra
terrestrial game the entire package
measures at 47 inches or 116 centimeters
so whoever's gonna get this
you might want to clean out your car no
maybe get an extra suit or strap it to
yourself like death stranding or beam it
up to your own ufo teleporting right out
of the game is the 23 inch crypto 137
figurine
a clone of a clone the figurine is a
life-sized replica of our favorite alien
invader this figurine comes decked out
in a full fuel mission attire and the
iconic zap o medic
holding a globe in his hands the crypto
sure looks the part of the tiny menace
to mankind
kryptos got your back as he clings onto
you in the form of a crypto backpack
true to the alien agenda of troubling
the humans
the backpack is more a stuffed toy than
a functional bag and can probably only
fit a mobile phone or wallet inside
also similar to the dna collectors
edition we have six lithographs
again not furon propaganda an
eye-popping anti-stress toy
a keychain and all in-game crypto skins
unfortunately you won't have any cow
beaming action in this set
the crypto 137 retails at a price of 450
singapore dollars
well if you can't wait to get your hands
on these sweet sweet collectibles you
can now stand a chance to win your very
own krypto 137 edition box set head over
to the link in the description below and
answer a couple of simple questions and
that's pretty much it
a short disclaimer this giveaway applies
to those of you living in singapore only
and let us know in the comments do you
love it do you hate it what's your
favorite piece in the collection don't
forget to support our channel by
subscribing and giving us a like so that
other geeks get a chance to watch this
video until then this is zeki from geek
culture and keep it geeky fam bams
[Music]